having that awareness that people are
still gonna care no matter how much I
mess up gives me the permission to go
try something new and make mistakes and
those who aren't willing to make
mistakes I think are gonna be stuck at
some point in their life here we are on
the Sunday special with Lewis house of
the school of greatness we're gonna get
to all of our questions about leadership
greatness sports life in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that
you're gonna die I'm sorry to break it
to you but you are going to plot and
when that happens you want to make sure
that your family is not left bereft this
is why you should be an adult and get
life insurance getting life insurance is
one of the more intimidating parts of
becoming an adult there are so many
options it's hard to know where to start
but making sure your family is
financially protected is really
important and also you don't want to be
buried in a pauper's grave I mean you
need life insurance so policy genius
created a website that makes it easy for
you to compare quotes get advice get
covered without extra fees or Commission
sales agents policy genius is the easy
way to get life insurance in minutes you
can compare quotes from top insurers and
find the coverage you need at a price
you can afford from there you can apply
online the advisors of policy genius
will handle all the red tape for you
don't even negotiate your rate with the
insurance company all part of their best
price guarantee and policy genius
doesn't just do life insurance they also
do disability insurance and homeowners
insurance and auto insurance so they can
always help you get covered fast if
you've been intimidated or frustrated by
insurance in the past try starting your
search of policy genius com again in
minutes you can compare quotes and apply
you can do the whole thing on your phone
right now in fact you probably should go
to policy genius the easy way to compare
and buy life insurance well lewis howes
thanks so much for joining the sunday
special really appreciate having you
here so let's just jump right in how did
you get into podcasting about greatness
because your story is kind of
fascinating
I moved to LA about six and a half years
ago and I was going through a breakup at
the time actually I'm actually going
through another one right now so what I
thought what he's having but I moved and
I was going through a breakup in a lot
of things in my life I was going through
a breakup in a business partnership that
I had in an intimate relationship those
in and also just like a lot of friends I
felt like we were breaking apart and I'd
moved here all this was happening and I
was just started to ask myself these
questions why is this happening the
common denominator
me I was at fault for all these things I
was responsible for the breakups in
every relationship and being in LA
traffic I was driving here today in the
rain there's always a lot of traffic I
remember being stuck and everyone was
stuck around me honking their horn
screaming and I said to myself like man
there's a lot of people who are stuck in
life just the way I feel stuck right now
there's got to be a way to reach people
and to inspire people who are feeling
stuck whether it's in traffic or just in
their life through breakups and I
thought to myself I need to learn I need
to humble myself I need to learn and ask
questions to the most inspiring people
in the world you were someone that came
on recently we've had incredible people
and that was six years ago and it's been
an amazing ride so how did you get into
sort of even even there right cuz your
background is really in sports are you
playing the Arena Football League and
you're obviously an athlete you plan the
O's handball team so how did you get
from point A to point B I think I was
always good at observing people you know
in school growing up I was in the
special needs classes it was hard for me
to read and write at a second grade
reading level in the eighth grade I
always struggled on tests and homework I
just I was the opposite of you right you
were excelled you skipped multiple
grades I was the one that should have
been held back but I kind of like
cheated in my way and asked friends to
give me the answers and then people
helped me with my homework all through
college it was a you know is the only
way I could really survive but with that
I was good at observing people I would
just study people all day long and
observe what made them tick why they did
the things they did why people were
afraid or insecure why they would say
certain things act a certain way why
they would bully other kids I would just
observe and I started asking a lot of
questions in high school in college and
I started to seek mentors at an early
age originally it was through coaches
and sports and then when I got into
business I just started seeking out
great leaders and business minds and the
more I asked questions the more I
learned information and I applied that
information after sports I applied in my
life like it was a sport I said I need a
coach I need a game plan
and I need to take action I named that
coach to give me feedback on the action
I took
and I just continue to repeat that cycle
in life and what's really fascinating I
think about what you're talking about
here is that it goes to a conversation
that I've had a lot of other guests
about the there's a lot of fear right
now the IQ gap this feeling that in our
economy and in our country and in a free
market that people at the upper end of
the IQ spectrum have this unbridgeable
advantage that you can't get anywhere if
you if you're not at the top of the IQ
spectrum I mean your story suggests that
and this isn't a rip on your IQ I mean
this is a story about like how you went
from being a place where you were behind
grade levels to doing what you're doing
now but it suggests that there's more
than one way to measure intelligence
that we're a little too narrow about
those yeah I think emotional
intelligence is something that people
are talking about more and more and you
hear about a lot of dyslexic
billionaires you know people that are
impacting the world leaders who were
dyslexic or who struggled in school who
dropped out of school but we're able to
connect with human beings we're able to
speak the language where someone's at
and meet people where they're at and I
think that's a powerful point on
leadership if you just expect everyone
to understand you and you're not coming
from a place of understanding them how
you to get them to move to shift to
change to evolve to take action on an
idea and that's why I tried to
constantly learn how to develop new
skills and master new skills and every
year I think about the things I'm most
afraid of I think about where are my
insecurities still where can I grow as a
human being and then I try to go all in
on those insecurities and master them so
they're not a fear anymore they become a
skill I spend some time listening to
show and reading some of your stuff and
one of the things that I really like
about what you talk about in terms of
leadership and also just in terms of
kind of taking life by the horns is they
and it come it comes off of you and
you're talking is is that you have real
spirit of adventure about life and do
you feel like that's kind of been lost
among a lot of Americans that we've kind
of been told we can't do things and and
so we're stuck in our own heads I think
so I think that a lot of us the thing
the common thing that I see the most is
people are have a lack of belief in
themselves they they they lack belief
they're very insecure and I think
they're just afraid to fail and I was
taught as an early age that you have to
fail if you want to succeed the more you
fail the more you're willing to succeed
and that's why for me as a kid I gotten
the act of taking on these challenges
early on any time was afraid I was just
like I'm sick and tired of feeling this
play I'm gonna take it on let's see what
happens and I don't care if anyone
doesn't like me cuz at the time no one
liked me so it didn't matter I was like
no one likes me I don't have friends
anyways so let me just try to get better
and now that I've got you know a core
group of family and friends it's like
even if I make a mistake and all my fans
leave me or followers leave me or
listeners stop listening I still have
people that care and having that
awareness that people are still gonna
care no matter how much I mess up gives
me the permission to go try something
new and I think that's the key it allows
me to be adventurous to wonder to try
and fail and make mistakes and those who
don't who aren't willing to make
mistakes I think are gonna be stuck at
some point in their life yeah it's
really interesting cuz you and I are
opposites in a lot of ways but this way
we're very similar I mean it sounds like
when I was growing up I obviously didn't
have tons of friends I was kind of
isolated I had my family specifically
and it's painful at the time but you
also sort of learned that it's your job
to forge forth and and if people never
seem to care about you you tend not to
care about what they think very much
right in the long run how did you deal
with that when you're a kid being not
the most popular kid I didn't deal with
it well I it struggled because all I
wanted was friends that's all I wanted
and I felt like I was constantly the
outcast again originally is because I
couldn't read and write and when the
teacher would ask us to read aloud in
class I would just stutter and so I just
get picked on and made fun of I was in
the special needs classes as well and so
I just constantly told myself that I was
stupid based on results you know the
results I was getting I was stupid I was
in the bottom four of my my class every
time we got a grade card I was in the
bottom four cuz they ranked us on our
grade cards so that didn't help but I
used a lot of my anger and put it into
being a great athlete
I said no one is ever gonna pick on me
again I'm gonna get so big so fast so
strong so talented as an athlete that
everyone's gonna want me on their team I
remember in third grade I was picked
last for a sports team in the class the
the teacher said ok were to go out to
recess were to play dodgeball and he
picked two captains and he said go ahead
and pick one by one
now I was thinking to myself I'm a
pretty good athlete
I want to be one of the first guys
picked right so the two captains they
pick one by one all the boys in the
class there's probably 20 boys 20 girls
and I'm thinking of myself man am I
really gonna be the last boy picked this
is like humiliating and then it comes
down to the last boy and then there was
me and so I start walking over to the
team that was next thinking I was gonna
be the next one picked little did I know
they started picking a girl and the next
girl and the next girl and the next girl
all the way until I was the last one by
default and that really resonated with
me at the time it really stuck with me
and made me angry cuz I felt just like
there was an attack against me you know
they were making fun of me they were
really singling me out and I remember
saying after that first off I just
dominated in that game I just like let's
throw the ball everything everything but
I said to myself like never again will I
get picked last and if you know so I'm
gonna do whatever it takes to become a
great athlete I knew I wasn't good in
school so I was like all this energy is
gonna go into developing my skills and I
as an athlete and that's what I did you
know I started to just go all-in and I
had to win at all costs I was a very
poor loser and I was a bad winner you
know winning still wasn't enough I still
had to like destroy people when I won
and I would all constantly beat myself
up for the couple mistakes I would make
in the game and I would didn't matter if
I was the highest scorer the MVP I was
like yeah but I messed that up I messed
that up so I would beat myself up for
winning and I was a sore loser when we
lost and it just drove me to get better
it wasn't until I was about thirty years
old actually that I realized that I had
a very big ego that I was driven to win
at everything I was driven to win in my
relationships I was driven to be right I
was driven to excel in sports and that's
when there's kind of moments you know
six years ago five six years ago really
came to me when I was going through this
breakup and everything I was like why am
I still struggling when I have a very
successful multi-million dollar business
I had a beautiful girlfriend I have
these great relationships I've achieved
all these accolades that seem good
but why am I still suffering and
struggling inside and it wasn't until I
was able to go back into and I think we
talked about this a little bit to go
back until all the times that I was felt
like I wasn't enough felt like I was
bullied picked on and just felt like I
didn't believe in myself when I went
back and all that and started to process
it that's when I started to realize why
I acted the way I did and when I started
to let go of a lot of the pain a lot of
frustration a lot of things I was
holding on to the forgiveness that I
needed to do that's when I finally felt
free
emotionally yeah I mean there's a lot
there and I think it sounds like from
different angle you know I have very
similar experiences this way and you
know for me it gave me a different
perspective on bullying so my
perspective on bullying is that I hate
bullies with a passion I think they're
awful I think we should do everything we
can to stop bullies but it doesn't give
me a lot of sympathy for necessarily
folks who are bullied and then use that
as an excuse not to try or to order to
suggest that the bullying is the
rationale for their future failures
right at a certain point you got to take
ownership of what happened to you and
turn it around as best you can I mean if
we're not talking about something that
is life-threatening or really
debilitating but as somebody who's
pretty viciously bullied myself that was
always fuel for the fire and this for me
right exactly and I think that that is
what I hope that's what people can treat
bullying as because life is full of
terrible things in terrible hardship
it's not fair that's right and you can
either react to that by trying harder or
you can react to it by kind of knuckling
under exactly and I think I realized
that I used the the fire from like the
bullying or just not feeling good enough
or whatever you know from family
challenges and struggles my parents my
brother was in prison for a few years
and so I didn't have friends during that
time either so I just I had a lot of
different things that I held on to and I
realized that the fuel and the fire that
I had to prove everyone wrong was so
powerful that it worked
it got me moving forward they got me to
develop at her skills I became a great
athlete I was an all-american and two
sports I played pro football all these
things happened but I still wasn't happy
rain feeling fulfilled and I was like
why isn't this working
like I am doing everything by the book
I'm working harder than ever
else I'm putting more time in the gym
you know I play by the rules all these
things but why am I still suffering
inside why am I still not feeling like
it's not enough and it wasn't until
again I started to really address these
things and tap into all the things from
my childhood and from breakups and
relationships and when I started to let
go that's when I started to feel a sense
of inner peace and I think there's a lot
of people who are very successful who
are big personalities who are who make a
lot of money but I see them and I talk
to them and they're suffering inside and
one of the things I want to try to do is
support people and overcoming that inner
suffering that pain that I think a lot
of us have held onto or hold onto still
and it's just a process so yeah well you
know ambition and drive it's it's kind
of a universal asset ready eats through
your apathy which is great because it
means that our normal tendency is to be
apathetic and to be lazy and when you're
ambitious it gets you up off your ass
makes you go do things but then you get
to a certain point and the assets starts
eating through the actual engine like
the engine that keeps you going it it
starts to it starts to eat you up inside
if you're talking about your life yeah
exactly and then there comes a point
where you realize that you actually
can't dance with the gal the branya that
that chip on your shoulder that ambition
that's actually become now an obstacle
to the happiness that you thought it was
gonna bring you in the first place it's
the enemy now it's like the demon inside
that you gotta let go of it's the thing
that fuels you to get there but it's not
the thing that's gonna help you be
fulfilled right exactly I mean what's a
fulfillment and happiness and like but
they're not long-term and I think that's
that's we gotta learn so so how much of
this has to do with what do you consider
sort of your purpose in life I mean what
would you consider success cuz obviously
had monetary success yeah you've had
success in different areas in sports
what do you consider success that
actually makes you happy what's the
stuff that makes you happy for me it's
knowing that I don't live with any
regrets so at least giving my full
effort on things that I'm that I love
that I'm excited about that are my
dreams or my fears it's like going
all-in on those things and if I fail at
least I know I went all-in for me that's
one measure of success another measure
of success is making my family proud you
know and doing doing well by my name
my last name my family the people that
raised me my siblings
and having them really respect me and
say you're doing a good job for me
that's important the third thing is
knowing that I left it all on the field
of life and making the maximum impact on
the maximum number of people I don't
know I downloaded this app a few weeks
ago called we croak I don't know if
you've heard of this yeah five times a
day it sends me a message that says
you're gonna die and I guess it's from
the the nation Bhutan I think we're five
times a day they practice their death or
they think about their death to have
them appreciate their life more and I'm
thinking about this a lot more it's like
I might be gone tomorrow I might walk
out of here hopefully I am safe but the
rain who knows and I may not be here am
I gonna be happy with the results I have
and the actions I took in this life so
for me it's just how can I make the
maximum impact on the maximum number of
people to help them live a better life I
don't know a better mission that I could
live by if I can help people feel better
live better reach their potential
achieve their dreams experience love on
the deepest levels for me I feel like
that's a pretty good measure of success
so I want to ask you a little bit about
your families you mentioned your parents
and your brother what was your family
growing up I mean on one side my my
parents were so loving and giving and
nurturing but on the other side they had
their challenges there was a lot of
arguments and fighting and
passive-aggressive energy in the home I
was the youngest of four at 8 years old
my brother went to prison for four years
for selling some drugs to an undercover
cop when he was in college and the war
on drugs and the 90s was a big deal so
they were just putting people away no
matter what they did and you know when I
was five not to get too deep but when I
was five I was I was raped by a man and
it was a very dark time it was very dark
because it really shaped my entire life
this one moment where I was sexually
abused it made me very defensive anytime
I felt like someone was trying to attack
me and
that was very challenging growing up in
Ohio as a straight man you know I was
also very I would say I love to be
around like my teammates brothers right
I love to like high-five them and put my
arm around guys and just like be a
loving brother right but any time I
showed any type of connection just like
as a brother
none intimate in any way was just like
don't be a don't be gay don't be
this it was always like bad that couple
with the bullying coupled with just
being made fun of
you know I was almost this tall when I
was like 10 years old so I was just like
this gangly goofy kid so I always felt
under attack that's the story I told
myself and it wasn't until I was able to
at 30 years old start to process I never
told anyone about being raped because I
always felt so ashamed I felt so guilty
I felt like no one was gonna love me no
one was gonna accept me they were gonna
blame me they were to make fun of me
it was gonna hurt my business everyone
was going to laugh at me and it wasn't
until I was 35 years ago that I that I
started to open up about it and talk
about it it was a scariest thing I've
ever done but it was also the most
freeing thing I've ever done because
people did embrace me they did accept me
and it brought me closer to people than
I ever thought it would you know when I
shared with my family members they were
all in shock and sad and hurt but they
also started to open up in powerful
beautiful ways with me about things I
never knew about them and so we created
a better connection and intimacy when I
shared with my friends same thing
happened they were just there for me
even more and it would build more trust
I decided to publicly open up about it
on my podcast five years ago but four
and a half years ago and I remember
saying this is gonna ruin my career I
don't know any other white straight jock
personality who's opened up about being
sexually abused and there's no model for
me to follow this but I felt like the
more I was telling people one-on-one the
more healing it was creating for them as
well and people are opening up to me
about their pain and their shame and
their guilt and insecurities
and the more I started to research about
how men are causing so much pain in the
world
so much suffering because they're not
just opening up about their shame I said
I got to do something about this and
even if I lose all my followers and I
lose all my money is gone I feel like at
least I lived part of a mission and a
purpose that I was here to do and when I
opened up about it it blew my mind
the emails I got hundreds of emails from
men who were 50 years old that said I
have four kids and a wife no one knows
this happened to me when I was 11 this
happened to me when I was six when I was
12 when I was five and people just
opened up one by one I became someone
they could share with I guess someone
they could trust and the healing that
happened after that for a lot of these
men just really inspired me and that's
why I started to talk about it more
that's why I wrote a book about men just
opening up and having a safe space to
share these things it doesn't have to be
with the world but just with your spouse
or a close friend or someone at the
church or a therapist or someone you can
trust to start opening up about the
things that you're most ashamed of most
heard by and the things you're angry
about because I just feel like there's a
lot of pain in the world there's a lot
of anger and there's a lot of hate and
if we can eliminate that then we can all
be more free have you gotten any
blowback from having for having told
those stories um I don't think I really
did I think maybe there was like a
couple people that that were I don't
know hurt or offended by me sharing but
it was so overwhelmingly positive that a
demon really recognized it it was a
maybe a couple people saying I shouldn't
have said it a certain way but it's been
life-changing for me but also for other
people so I just continue to talk about
it and also that experience now no
longer has control over me where it used
to define me
it used to be any time I felt attacked I
would go after and want to fight someone
whether it be online physically I just
wouldn't want to fight people and that's
not a good way to live life just mostly
like 22 attacks than one is it's really
fascinating is obvious we live in this
me too moment where a lot of people are
worried about exactly this kind of stuff
the abuse of women the abuse of men the
the sexual abuse of people and there
seems to be a baseline assumption that
most Americans are somehow not
sympathetic that there there needs to be
a massive
shift and how most Americans think about
this stuff and I mean I'm coming at a
different angle because thank God that
never happened to me but it seems to me
that that may be exaggerated the most
Americans are really not looking to jump
down the throat of somebody who is
abused that most Americans are on the
side of people who are abused and are
looking to figure out exactly how they
can help yeah I think the statistic
right now is one in one of four women
have been sexually abused and one six
men have been sexually abused or six
boys and that we know of and so the
challenge is that this is happening more
frequently than then we realize it's
probably happening to someone that you
know close to you if you've got five guy
friends chances are one of you has
experienced this and I think it's just
lets us know they're like there's a lot
more things have happened to people that
we're not even aware of because people
aren't talking about it and people are
ashamed they're insecure they're afraid
of what people were to say they want to
be rejected what people know about them
and I think we suffer when we hold these
things in we suffer we struggle and we
start to make poor decisions when we're
emotionally triggered when we're under
attack emotionally or physically we're
less peaceful in our responses I think
that's what if this is all about it's
like how can we come together more as a
world as a humanity to serve a greater
purpose so why we're all here you know
less attacking and more service so you
talk about some of this in your new book
the mask of masculinity specifically
talking about you know vulnerability and
all this what do you think the mask is I
mean when you refer to the mask
masculinity what is that man I think we
all wear different masks you know I wore
the athlete mask and the know-it-all
mask you know there's some people that
some guys have the Joker mask who are
always the funny guy they're always like
the laugh the laugh of the party
there's the invincible mask the guy that
just takes on every challenge who just
like the daredevil who thinks he's never
gonna get hurt we put on these masks
essentially to try to fit in you know I
wear this athlete's mask and this this
egoic and know what all masks because I
wanted to prove my worthiness an
acceptance of other people whether it
was girls guys teachers coaches didn't
matter
trying to prove something based on
insecurities when we reveal our
when we take off the mask and we realize
oh this is actually really scary when
someone sees all of us we stop
protecting the things that were afraid
of and someone sees us
it's terrifying because we're unsure of
how people respond you know when the
comedian constantly tells a funny joke
he's gonna get someone to laugh and he
knows that people want to be around that
so it's comfortable when I tell a joke
people are gonna laugh I'm gonna have
friends they're gonna like me what if I
don't tell a joke for a week and people
stop laughing are they gonna like who I
really am are they gonna like what I
have to say that if it's not constantly
making a joke or constantly doing
something to prove my worth and I think
that's what we get to learn how to be
it's just more more open more revealing
less surface level that's projecting our
mask that doesn't sound like it's
specifically masculine or feminine so
what do you mean when you speak about
like masculinity per se so obvious
there's a lot of talk these days about
toxic masculinity or the problems with
masculinity yeah so what's your take on
on masculinity I think I think people's
opinions of it I think we grew up with
an opinion of masculinity that doesn't
work fully right now where you have to
be strong you have to be the provider
you have to be certain things you have
to never show emotion you can never cry
you can never tell people how you feel I
think some of the times that works you
know you want to be a provider you want
to be strong in certain times but there
are certain times that you can also be
vulnerable and you can shift in and out
of it
you don't have to be the standard of
masculinity that was projected when we
grew up as kids which is like you've got
to sleep with all the girls you've got
to make lots of money you've got to have
a great job otherwise you're not a real
man I think that just is not accurate
I'm not saying you should be like the
softest human being in the world and cry
every single day I don't think that
works either but I think you get to be
able to flex in and out of this toxic
masculinity that doesn't serve us
anymore in moments yes
be strong stand up for what you need to
you know fight against certain things
that are unjust but you don't have to be
that way a hundred percent of the time
if it's hurting you and hurting the
people around you so just see how you're
affecting the people around you
at least the closest people around to if
you're hurting people around you is that
ideal of masculinity good or can you
shift it that's what I'm sorry yeah I
feel like we've sort of shifted it it's
interesting because I feel like a lot of
what people consider to be traditional
masculinity is a little bit overwrought
meaning enough because we'd all seen
movies from the 1930s and 40s we think
okay John Wayne is that's what
masculinity was but the reality is that
you know being a man was always about
really protecting and providing those
were these were the two things and maybe
we moved too far in the direction of
protection and providing without
thinking about how we maintain our own
health or mental our own emotional
health and mental sanity but I get the
feeling from today's men that sometimes
it's too far in the other direction then
we're very much focused on our own
emotions and and sure we're focused on
vulnerability but we forget about
responsibility and we'll forget about
questing forth and protecting it and all
of these absolutely and that's why I
think it's like don't go the other side
and just be completely forget these
things just like the masks you can put
them on at certain times don't keep them
on all the time you know be the funny
guy in that moment that you need to be
funny but when you're all at a funeral
or there's a very sensitive moment don't
have the mask on and be funny all the
time learn how to use different emotions
learn how to shift your energy to
connect with people in the right
settings and I think that's an evolved
human being not just a man that's an
evolved human being who learns about
their surroundings what people are
feeling what they're going through and
knows how to shift their their energy
their words their communication in that
moment I mean this is one of these areas
where it's so funny because you don't do
politics and I do politics but the truth
is that the consensus that we have about
these issues is pretty broad and I feel
like in the political world all these
false these false breaks happen all
these false dichotomies where on the one
hand you have Gillette doing commercials
about toxic masculinity yeah there's one
this week about how men are have been
bringing up boys to be bullies and
sexual harassing and on the other side
you have a bunch of people saying hold
up hold up a second without fathers
these boys end up disasters that most
toxic masculinity is not the result of
men in boys lives it's the result of men
not being in in boys lives and you know
one day you're gonna be married and have
kids what how do you expect it to be the
man in your
his life it's a great question I think
I'm gonna have to learn from a lot of
successful fathers and start to ask them
a lot of smart questions I'll start
having them on my show but I think it's
it's being example and setting a
standard of being responsible you know
being responsible for your actions for
the things you say the things you do and
I mean I'm gonna be pushing my kids to
want to be the best they can be in their
own way but also I remember my father
would he would cry at different times in
movies I remember like every three or
four months I would see him cry and on
one side the the kids in my school
if you cried in school you were just
made fun of a picked on so I would never
show emotion growing up because I didn't
want my friends to pick on me even more
than I was being bullied but I would see
my father tear up during movies or in an
emotional moment in our family I would
see him cry in a very sensitive way and
yet here here was this strong provider
very strong large in the life big guy he
was actually an insurance salesman you
know plug to your insurance ad in the
beginning I'm very successful insurance
made a lot of money father of four
married for 30 years and Harry was
showing emotion in a time back in the
80s and 90s where that wasn't really
acceptable and I never saw that from
other parents and so it it gave me a a
model it said okay you can still be
strong but also like allow for emotion
to come out when you feel it and not
just bottle it all up and feel stressed
and feel overwhelmed and anxious because
you're not expressing that no I didn't
see him crying every day and out in
public and all these other things it was
in like certain settings but for me I
thought that was really important to
model that to just say hey if you have a
feeling you can express your feelings
and it's okay so I think I'll be
expressive to my kids as well in that
way and I want them to feel extremely
loved and supportive so that I remember
I was interviewing Kobe Bryant and he
said the first year you got into
basketball there was a summer he got
into basketball when he was like 12
years old or something and he didn't
score a single point the whole summer
and he went on to become one of the
great
basketball players and arguably athletes
of all time and I said how did you go
into playing and what was the greatest
lesson that your father taught you that
made you so dominant and he said to
takobi he said that no matter whether he
scores a doesn't score wins or loses
he's gonna love him the same way and
Kobe said that gave him permission to go
and fail and go and pursue it even
harder because he knew that his father
was gonna love him no matter what I
think there's a lot of parents that base
their love on performance and results
and they hold back sometimes if they
didn't get the result that day wish that
their kids got so learning more lessons
like that like making sure you love your
kids no matter what so I know you're a
political guy it seems like these days
pretty much every topic for some reason
or other becomes political it doesn't
seem to matter what it is whether it's
the sporting world whether it's the
advertising world so I'm not gonna ask
how you vote because frankly it's your
business but you know if you had any
sort of core political convictions about
what government should be doing do you
have it do you have any sort of
political convictions on this sort of
stuff I know the least about politics
and any terminology and anything that
any party is what they're doing I really
don't watch much news
I'm sure give me a specific question
maybe of like I just want people to come
to bed it's come together and love each
other more as weird as that sounds I
want people to fight less and feel free
to pursue what they want and so whatever
government supports that where it's it's
I think a government that inspires
people to pursue what they want to be
more productive to be more loving to be
more inclusive to be less to hate people
less I think that's what we need you
know all the taxes and this and that
it's like I spend so much money on taxes
but I feel like it's the price I paid to
have the freedoms here in California and
opportunities that I'm just like
whatever I got to pay whatever have to
pay it gives me the opportunity not as
much as you're paying the answer is you
don't have to pay as much as you're
paying opportunities but sure I wish I
don't have to you right don't worry you
don't but it's just California but in
any case the reason I ask that is
because you know we're where I come from
the sort of what you're doing which is
an attempt to build
social fabric all that stuff seems to be
stuff that we really do outside of
government so you mentioned the idea
that you know a government that can
foster this stuff I'll be honest I've
never seen a government that's capable
of fostering what we needed to do in
order to make that happen I mean I don't
think that the government is capable of
that meaning that I think the
connections that we have with the people
around us the connections with our
family the connection with our friends
all that happens in the absence of
government that when government comes in
and tries to get between me and my
family or make solutions for us what
they're doing instead is they're
preventing me from from building the
communities that I want to build and so
what you're doing and we'll take it back
inside of politics here what what you're
doing and building social fabric is
actually a social good on a political
level because without that social fabric
where we're all connected then you do
need a government to come in and and
artificially build a reason for us all
to be in the same place at the same time
other if we were able to voluntarily get
together see each other as brothers and
sisters as opposed to enemies then you
don't need government to put its heavy
foot down and try and compel things from
the top down right that's sort of that
sort of the viewpoint in any case there
you go okay so a lot of learn from you
know so let me ask you about sort of
your religious background so you're
obviously a very we'll driven guy a lot
of your advice is about sort of jumping
in and and taking the bull by the horns
and you have that you have the power to
do certain things so where are you on a
religious level I grew up in a religion
called Christian Science you ever heard
of the solution it's a very small
religion and for me I still don't fully
understand it I don't go to church
necessarily anymore maybe once a year
once or twice a year but I remember
going to church every week and and every
Wednesday night through these things
called testimonial Wednesday night
testimonials where people would talk
about the healings they had from from
the practice of the religion and the
original was founded by a woman and Mary
Baker Eddy and what I really took from
the religion is that it's all about mind
over matter everything that I learned
was your thoughts and your ideas shape
your reality and we are all spiritual
beings that means we're not actually
physically here just an idea and
therefore an idea can never be
physically hurt and it was always very
confusing because I was like well what
is this
right it's like I have these desires
these urges but I worked for me very
well in sports and whenever I was in
conflict I was just like I'm just an
idea and if I have an idea and I
continue to build the belief of the idea
strong then I can do anything and
anytime I was hurt or injured my mindset
was stronger than my physical body the
way it gave me the advantage in games
and in sports and it allowed me to push
myself so far because I just believed
that was an idea that could never be
hurt and again there's there's certain
things about the religion that I really
love and certain things that I don't
understand still and that's why I'm not
constantly practicing it but I gave me a
great foundation to continue to ask
questions about why we're here and the
purpose of it all and while I'm here I
might as well make them most of it and
and be a good idea as opposed to a bad
one so what's your day like on a daily
basis I mean do you get up in leadership
all day or like I get I mean I get up
and I think the body is important though
even though I focus on the mind a lot I
try to push the mind through pushing the
body so I get up and I train usually
either with a trainer I do a class or
something in the morning I you know I
meditate which is the same thing as
prayers means it's really just focusing
on how I can be a better person this day
and how I can serve humanity and a
higher level I really look at myself as
a servant to to my skill sets like how
can I serve people how can I serve my
audience and I really look at that as
the definition of masculinity it's
someone who's in service and that's what
I look at it and for me it doesn't
matter what shape it takes as long as
I'm helping people improve their lives
that's my whole mission every single day
so I work out I meditate or pray
whatever you want to call it and I
really focus on how I'm gonna do that
that day my mission is to serve 100
million people every single week I'm
nowhere close to it now but that's the
goal but I'm working towards and I do a
lot of what you do you know I'm
interviewing people I'm working on a
couple of books right now you know
filming documentaries I'm doing
different media content to try to spread
the message of that service and reach
those people so you talked a little bit
earlier about
your fears and how to overcome them
right now what are your greatest fears
man I think I'm learning too I don't
have to learn from you on how you do
this because I've never really gotten a
lot of criticism right never they got a
lot of criticism until recently
not because of you yeah yeah I gotta
stop there but just like people are
starting to attack my character attack
my whole life's work for one or two
things that they didn't agree with let's
say and I've never really had to face
that on a large scale I faced it on
smaller scale but when you know people
start attacking me and start spamming
online things that are rumors are not
true and then people start to believe
that that's a that's a it's just kind of
like man how do I I guess it just
happens for everyone as they continue to
have a bigger audience and so I'm trying
to learn that this is gonna happen you
know I saw the rock who I'm actually a
big fan of had something like every news
outlet talked about now he there was an
interview he talked about Millennials
ripping on snowflakes and but it wasn't
how something right we were real happy
about her nephew never gave the
interview Yeah right it was never him or
something and it's just like no matter
how good and I feel like the guy is
constantly trying to do good on them
yeah constantly like spreading
positivity and giving back it doesn't
matter how much good you try to do
someone wants to see you fail
some wants to see you fall someone is
jealous someone is so insecure that they
try to attack you and it's just kind of
I just wish the world wasn't that way
but it is and so my fear is learning how
to navigate that and that's why I'm like
maybe I'll have some conversations with
you off camera to see how you've handled
it and manage it emotionally because
it's something that's happened and
recently that I'm like okay this is new
and I feel like I'm moving through it
pretty well but I'm just not sure man is
this gonna be happening for the rest of
my life hey yeah I mean the answer is
yes I mean how do you handle I mean you
get someone who's like attacking all of
your character all your life's work all
the things you've done well you know
it's very difficult because when you're
young
yeah especially because we had this
common history being bullied
what you learn is that you have to
really grow a hard shell and then as you
get older you're like okay but I want
the hard shell but I also want you know
I want to be like a Sabra fruit I want
to be have like the soft center where
you know so my friends and family I'm
soft also I can take criticism so the
shells not completely impermeable I want
people to be able to make a critique of
me and I want to be able to accept that
question internalize it and give
feedback and if you're a good person
you're constantly trying to make
yourself better along the way but
there's a lot of bad faith criticism
that happens and that's why I think that
in the end and this is the part of my
life that I've reached now is that you
have to actually develop a core that is
not permeable there's there's the stuff
that you actually believe so strongly
that that's not actually permeable where
a criticism actually has to bounce off
its there's this outer layer of most
things bounce off and then there's an
inner layer which is okay I accept some
of this criticism and some of it that I
don't it's more of a filter and then
there's this hard core of principle that
no one can invade and if they invade
that you just it's rejected out of hand
and trying to figure that out a really
hard barrier because you want us because
it's a hard balance you want to make
sure that that barrier isn't too large
so that you can't accept criticism or so
that you can't be sensitive to other
people but you want to make sure that
it's there because if it's not there
then you just get shot right through
right it goes it goes through one side
and out the other and it mortally wounds
you and that's that's really difficult
because you know it there's no way it
doesn't hurt of course in her eyes I
mean this is any time you're under
attack for something you feel like is
unjust it doesn't matter how bright
you're trying to be it's like why what
are these people so you know yeah and
and usually what you find is that
somebody else's insecurities that are
driving all of that other so they're
insecure they want to see whatever right
they want to see you go down because
they they have a problem with you but
it's bad faith but the bad faith is
really rooted in something that happened
too many years ago they're not taking
the actions they wish they were taking
right exactly and and you know that that
helps to a certain extent but it really
does mean that you have to I think that
that core also includes other people
meaning that you eat one of the ways to
make sure that that core is is the
correct size and strength is to make
sure that you actually have no men
around you like having bad leaders
surround themselves with us met and bad
leaders surround themselves with people
who are telling them they're doing the
right thing all the time good leaders
surround themselves in OMA and saying
you're not allowed to do this you're not
allowed to do that but also you know are
not
we post everything you do they're trying
to guard you from yourself and they're
also trying to protect you at the same
time so getting feedback from a group of
people you actually trust is difficult
it's hard to find great friends you know
I'm not you and I know I'm not I'm not a
friend's person because I think that
most friends have interests that are
disparate from yours I mean they have
their own lives they've their own
priorities and sometimes that conflicts
but you know when you for me my core is
my wife my kids my parents and that's
pretty much it right and then I have
like a couple of very close friends who
really maybe only one really close
friend who I bounce things off of and
then a bunch of people who I take their
advice under advisement but you know I
think that that's that's necessary you
do have to you do have to have that at
hard core because if it's not there then
you will get blown away I mean as you
get bigger it's that the pressures grow
larger I mean there's more weight
there's just more weight and we live in
an ugly time right I mean people are
gonna go through everything you ever
said everything you ever did they're
gonna dig up everything every person you
ever heard here's your tweet whatever
been years ago tweet I'll go talk to all
your old girlfriends and try to find out
something bad that you did or said or
something so that's where I'm at right
now it's figuring out how to navigate
that and and I'm also like actually
appreciative and grateful for because
I'm like you know if you're everyone's
gonna have that after doing something
positive right and it gives you an
opportunity also to sort of clean your
plate of it meaning that something comes
up from 10 years ago you feel bad about
it comes up you're like right I screwed
that up and now I have the opportunity
to just so taking responsible for
everything and also purging people you
know I'm just like purging people like
followers who are just taking the
assumptions of rumors and saying oh
you're this bad guy now because of this
thing or whatever I'm like okay well if
that's what you want to believe I'm
sorry to see you go but honey I mean
you're in the social media world how do
you handle social media because I feel
like it's eating my life so uh yeah it's
tough I think this has actually been a
good time since I've had like some of
these experiments come out of the
woodwork over the last whatever a few
months I've allowed I've removed myself
from reading it you know I have a team
that's working on it that just sees all
this stuff and just to leave some blocks
people right away and I think that's
powerful for me it's like removing
myself from the day-to-day of being on
Instagram and allowing other people to
to do that so I can focus on the bigger
mission and that's been really helpful
as having that before I answer more I
was curious what is the third layer core
for you you said there's three layers
what's the one or two beliefs that you
hold on to no matter
I'm in the center that's like nothing
will penetrate those things well I think
honestly for anyone you you have to
believe that you are well-intentioned
yeah if you don't believe that you're
well-intentioned then you're going to
collapse right if you believe that what
you're actually motivated by is greed or
by some or fame or something hours
before exactly then but but for most
people it really is fame and money right
fame and money or personal love if
you're motivated by those any of those
three things you get yourself in real
trouble if you feel like you're
motivated by something that's that's
true that you actually want the best for
the world you want the best for other
people then when somebody attacks you
it's like well that's just not true yeah
right you can just reject that out of
hand like if somebody it would be like
if somebody said to me you don't love
your wife a bill that's necessarily like
it said I wouldn't get angry it's just
like it's like saying if somebody said
to me you don't love your kids like
that's just things that are just not
true
bounce off of you it's the stuff that
feels like that niggles at you and your
mind you feel like maybe it's half true
like am i doing that because I'm
hand-rearing am I doing that because I'm
just trying to be successful am I doing
that because that's the stuff that
bothers you and so you have to wake up
and then that's what allows you to be a
good person is cleansing those
influences everything not just the
outside criticism but cleansing yourself
at those feelings maybe I am doing it
because I'm doing it for for bad reasons
okay so then I have to not do that and
that makes me better and that that
allows me to keep that core intact so so
the core is it's not that you're
stubborn and not seeing the criticism
it's that in order to maintain that core
honestly you actually have to keep
polishing it there has to be polish
regular basis constant reflecting yeah I
mean that's that's that's I think I'm
spending more time reflecting and less
time projecting and I think that that's
that's something I've been trying to
work on it's is difficult you know it's
rough okay so back to relationship so
you've been dating a lot more recently
than I have my dating experience is
basically none and then met my wife
three months of dating proposal marriage
11 years of marriage July so I - kids
yeah exactly it was it was all very
purpose is the purpose it was the
purpose driven dating basically I knew I
was gonna get married - how's dating
former marriage you know obviously you
have been through more relationships and
more dating experience than I have
what's your advice for for guys who are
trying to date in in today's world oh my
gosh
I think the more you work on yourself
and your inner confidence the easier
it'll be the less you'll have to like
make things up the less you're gonna
have to say something certain line
you're just gonna be yourself because
you're working on yourself the more
confident you are the more going to
attract a confident individual and so I
would just keep it relaxed you know for
me I would keep it relaxed don't try to
work so hard in it but also give
yourself a challenge to put yourself out
there you know whether it's every day
I'm gonna talk to someone who I think is
interesting whether it be online or
someone I meet at a coffee shop I'm
gonna give myself the challenge to
potentially get rejected and the more
you do that you're gonna build
confidence because you're gonna learn
how to communicate to people better who
you're curious about her or attracted to
and I remember when I was 16 I was
terrified to speak to girls couldn't
speak to girls cuz I was afraid I was
insecure I felt stupid all these things
and I gave myself that challenge when I
was 16 in the summer I said anytime
there's a girl that I'm attracted to or
I think is cute
I'm going to walk right up to them and
have a conversation and I never could do
that before and it was terrifying to me
and the first couple weeks I just got
rejected over and over curls laughs to
meet girls ran away from me and all
these things now my worst nightmare
happened but little by little I was like
oh I'm never see that person again it
doesn't matter right like it's okay to
get rejected let me just go back again
and knowing that I'm going to fail it
made it more easier for me to be
confident the next time so that's what I
would say is give yourself a challenge
be more of yourself by working on
yourself and increasing your confidence
with different skills that you want to
learn and you're gonna you're gonna
project real confidence as opposed to
some pickup line and you're gonna
attract the right people yeah so this is
one of those areas where you know I
didn't as I say I haven't had a lot of
dating experience but the dating
experience that I did have was
extraordinarily productive so I batted
basically a thousand in my very life I
didn't date very much at all and then I
dated and I got married and it's great
so yeah it's it but you don't want to
find a little piece of advice that I had
from a great relationship coach for
women who came on my show his name is
Matt ha
he said if you want to attract the right
partner create a list of all the things
you want from those people you know
everything write it down everything you
want to attract from that person and
then become those exactly this is this
is exactly right and when I see guys who
are whining about they can't get a date
you know very often it's because you
don't deserve a date man no I mean it
because you haven't made yourself a
person who is dateable exactly and it
happens for women too you see people who
rail against reality this is this one my
pet peeves just in life I'm dating too
is people who rail against the realities
you'll see somebody who's not in shape
and they're railing they're not finding
enough attractive partners and it's like
well why don't go to the gym work under
so I think it's it's it's not somebody
else's responsibility to be attracted to
you yeah right it's your responsibility
to make yourself attractive if you want
this thing I mean in any other layer of
life you would recognize this and
there's a you know there's a lot of
people that are just like saying just
love yourself for who you are yes and
continue to work on yourself every
single day maybe usako because you can
love yourself for who you are and where
you're at and all the things you've done
in your life but that's not gonna get
you where you want to be doesn't mean
everybody else has to love it exactly
you loving yourself is not you're gonna
attract what you want you've got to
continue workers yeah exactly and and I
think that this is it's one of those
areas where again it's easier to project
out into the world what you'd like then
for you to actually make yourself into
something into something useful to
somebody else Rosario unattractive yeah
yeah and and I also think that we have
the society set up certain barriers and
expectations I think that men think that
women for example don't actually want
them to be straightforward right we've
watched too many movies where it's like
somebody becomes friends with the girl
men ends up with the girl and the best
way to get friend-zoned is to actually
become friends with the girl first I've
I've never been a fan of this particular
strategy straight forward I see these
guys that are either dating in groups is
like you'll see guys and girls go out in
groups together I'm thinking what are
you doing hey I've never maybe this is
just because I have a wonderful wife but
yeah yeah you're a director like I'm
looking to get married are you ready
this is this is pretty much it yeah I
mean on the first date yeah but it was
but it was really you know there's this
I think the culture right now because
we've created this fear between the
sexes where women are very much afraid
that men are gonna victimize them and
men are afraid of being rejected by
women and destroyed by women that what
it's created is this this dearth of men
who are willing to just walk up to it
ask her on a date yeah and I think
that's actually what women are looking
for him women want a guy who is going to
be strong enough and brave enough to
walk up and just say hello all the way
when I talk to you said that they would
like that there's only maybe one or two
women who are like yeah I don't want
anyone to come up to me when I'm alone
in a coffee shop
it's very rare I've heard it a couple of
times it's very rare most women are like
no one talks to me anymore
or the only way they talk to me is which
is by liking a photo on Instagram
because it's like the safe way it's from
a distance but I wish someone would come
up to me I wish someone would talk to me
it doesn't mean you have to be sleazy
and hit on someone you can just have a
conversation be a human being and I
think we've lost the art of just human
connection between the sexes what do you
think is the best way to meet somebody
so I had it easy my sister fix me up
with my wife I don't think it should be
easy I think you should challenge
yourself that's why it's like people are
taking the the swipe left and swipe
right approach with I've heard great
stories of people finding marriages and
relationships from that but I think
we're afraid to get rejected so much
that we hide behind other layers to try
to meet someone
again not wrong I just think it's gonna
feel that much better when you do the
hard work anytime you do the challenging
scary hard work you're gonna feel more
proud of yourself it's not easy I'm not
saying it's gonna be fun when you get
rejected 10 times in a row but I think
you learn how to become a better person
through that process of rejection and
that's what makes you a better human
being so random question for you since
you're sports guys so I need to ask you
since you did play actual professional
football you know do you think that
there is a I know random question is
there a future to football eirick people
gonna let their kids play fool at your
kids play football that's a good
question my mom wouldn't let me play
until I was 15 and I pretty much just
said I'm doing this you know looking
back I don't know if I like it was the
greatest time in my life
and it set me up for so many
opportunities but I have so many
injuries oh I broke three ribs twice
both my shoulders are messed up ankles
and the head trauma I literally think I
was just stupid in school from hitting
so much in my head you know I don't know
where that's gonna hit lead in the
future you know while the I just I led
with my helmet every single play it's
who knows how that's gonna affect me
long-term luckily I feel pretty good
right now I feel like it's
has it anyway but they're changing the
rules so much where you can't hit with
the head anymore and I think if they
continue to do that it'll be around for
long you can just go to flag football at
a certain point here no I mean it's
getting so soft in my opinion it's like
gosh these guys have it you know it's so
soft because of the rules it's not on
them it's the refs you know but um I
think it's good I think and I think that
I think there's gonna be room I think
it'll go flag football no there'll be
room for a UFC type football league
where people are just like you know what
people signed up to get their brains
knocked rugby rugby rugby will make a
comeback so um you know when it comes to
your sort of future where do you see
yourself five years from now man I
really just want to be a symbol of of
inspiration and positivity I want to
impact 100 million people a week that's
my current mission so everything I do is
focus on how can I create media and
information that supports reaching 100
million people a week to give them
different ideas solutions examples
inspiring stories like yours to have an
example to improve their life so have
you been interviewed a bunch of people's
your favorites aside from the obviously
most controversial yeah getting all the
I like I think when I have spiritual you
know thought leaders or former pastors
on who just have different ideas about
life I've had you know Kobe Bryant was
great I've had you know Tony Robbins was
something that I was fascinated by I've
had on a few times I like having
billionaires on Sara Blakely who was the
youngest female billionaire in America
she was fascinating I like to just not
make it the same person you know I've
had world-class athletes to billionaires
to spiritual leaders to entrepreneurs
and for me it's it's learning from all
types of people and mixing it up so not
having the same person every time but
constant learning different perspectives
and different belief sets from
individuals for me that's what's
exciting and not saying I'm gonna take
every new belief from someone but what's
one thing I can grab and start testing
and applying to prove my life so I like
people of all walks of life and who are
your chief influences going on
I had some great coaches that I really
leaned on when I was trying to be a
great athlete who were really
influential my dad and my mom obviously
were very inspiring my dad would always
you know he was a life insurance
salesman so he worked very hard and he
would come home every night and tuck me
in and you know say a prayer with me and
he came to every sports game in high
school and I went to a private boarding
school and he would fly every week and
come see me and was on the field taking
photos so again he was another great
example of like how to be there for for
me and as a son like man he was always
there for me a lot of the other parents
weren't there and I thought that was a
great example so yet coaches parents my
older brother was a hero of mine he's 11
years older and even though he was in
prison for four years I would go visit
him every weekend we would take it two
and a half hour drive to visit him in
the visiting room and I learned a lot
from being in a prison every single week
by seeing other inmates with their
families you know some of these inmates
were so emotionally and mentally free
yet they were imprisoned their whole
life or going to be in prison their
whole life and then I would come in the
outside world and see that there were so
many people who were physically free but
emotionally trapped mentally trapped in
bars and their own hearts and I thought
that was like the greatest crime that we
commit is being free physically but not
reaching our potential when there are
people behind bars who are emotionally
and mentally free some of them and don't
have the opportunities we do anymore
because of the actions they've committed
so I'm influenced by a lot of people I'm
inspired by a lot of people even people
that maybe like the worst of the worst I
feel like I can learn from anyone and
that's what I try to do so I have one
final question for you I do want to ask
you what is the worst advice you've ever
received I don't know find out what the
worst advice you've ever received is it
and we'll have Lois house answer that
question in just one second but if you
want to hear the answer you have to go
over to Daley wire comm and hit
subscribe that's all you have to do just
subscribe and hear the end of our
conversation over there at Daley
wire.com this is gonna be a good one so
make sure you subscribe well Lewis Howes
thank you so much for stopping by his
book is the mask of masculinity check
out his podcast the school of greatness
this is real pleasure happy thank you so
much thank you avenge Shapiro shows
Sunday special is produced by Jonathan
hey executive producer Jeremy boring
associate producer Mathis Glover edited
by Donovan Fowler audio is mixed by
Dylan Kate's hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera title graphics by Cynthia
and Guillot the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday
special is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
[Music]